[Musica]
buonasera buonasera a tutti
potrei cominciare dicendo che non si
torna mai uguali a come si è partiti
questo sarebbe già una risposta alla
domanda che mi è stata formulata mi è
stato chiesto di raccontarvi cosa accade
al nostro cervello quando facciamo nuove
esperienze
la risposta è potenzialmente molto
semplice il nostro cervello si modifica
e tanto è vero non solo dal punto di
vista funzionale non cambiano solo le
operazioni svolte dal nostro cervello
il nostro cervello si modifica dal punto
di vista strutturale cambia la propria
conformazione i cambiamenti strutturali
e funzionali che hanno luogo ben che
possano conservarsi nel tempo non sono
mai irreversibili
ed è possibile che dei cambiamenti nella
struttura nella funzione del nostro
sistema nervoso centrale si sviluppino
per tutta la durata della nostra
esistenza buona notizia per i più
pessimisti indipendentemente dall'età
la scoperta della natura a plastica del
sistema nervoso centrale è stata in
assoluto una delle più entusiasmanti
nella storia della fisiologia umana anzi
tutto questo ha permesso di sconfessare
alcuni falsi concetti a proposito del
cervello si credeva una volta che
raggiunta la propria maturazione
strutturale macroscopica il che
generalmente avviene intorno alla prima
adolescenza il cervello fosse incapace
di modificarsi se non in senso
involutivo e cioè per perdita di
sostanza come avviene nel corso
dell'inverno fisiologico nel corso di
alcune malattie
mi vengono in mente le malattie
neurodegenerative dell'alzheimer è la
più famosa di questa o le malattie
cerebrovascolari come l'ictus
soprattutto la scoperta della neuro
plasticità ha permesso di comprendere un
attimino più in profondità le ragioni
per le quali l'uomo meglio adattandosi a
questo ecosistema rappresenta la specie
dominante del pianeta terra
la neuroplasticità è la ragione per la
quale io trovo che ponti e passaggi sia
un titolo splendido per un intervento
sul sistema nervoso centrale
il motore del cambiamento
e infatti
flusso di informazioni in ingresso nel
nostro sistema nervoso centrale ed
atteso che la possibilità di accesso
delle informazioni al nostro cervello è
definita dalle esperienze con le quali
ci misuriamo e dal comportamento che noi
andiamo assumendo possiamo affermare che
il nostro comportamento delle nostre
esperienze modificano il nostro cervello
non dico il falso
se dico che il vostro cervello non sarà
uguale dopo aver partecipato a questa
conferenza
se è vero che il motore del cambiamento
del sistema nervoso e il flusso di
informazioni vero è che gli attori
protagonisti dei cambiamenti che hanno
luogo nel nostro cervello sono le
cellule del sistema nervoso che si
chiamano neuroni il sistema molto
complesso ciascuno di noi all'incirca
100 miliardi di neuroni i messaggi che
le cellule si scambiano tra di loro le
cellule comunicano attraverso dei
messaggeri chimici che si chiamano
neurotrasmettitori e neuromodulatori e
le strutture lungo le quali corrono le
informazioni queste strutture sono dei
veri e propri ponti si chiamano sinapsi
in realtà rispetto ai ponti che siamo
abituati a vedere a percorrere nelle
nostre città hanno degli attributi
appena diversi che consentono loro di
partecipare al rimaneggiamento continuo
che fa del nostro cervello una materia
vivente per tutta la nostra esistenza
le sinapsi sono i nostri termini dei
punti modellabili che cambiano
continuamente nel corso dell'esperienza
e cambiano per in ragione del flusso di
informazioni che attraversa ogni
qualvolta un cambiamento si verifichi le
cellule che si sono scambiate le
informazioni apprendono nuove modalità
funzionali imparano a fare nuove
operazioni
ed è nella neuroplasticità allora che si
annida il segreto dell'apprendimento e
della conoscenza che ci appartiene come
specie dominante su questo pianeta
cerchiamo di chiarire alcune cose tutti
voi avete una certa familiarità con la
vicinanza concettuale che esiste tra le
nuove esperienze e l'apprendimento tutti
pensiamo ogni volta che incontriamo una
nuova persona o visitiamo nano la città
ci cimentiamo con un nuovo lavoro di
poter apprendere qualcosa
la neuroplasticità rappresenta la
sostanza biologica di questa possibilità
ovviamente esiste un enorme variabilità
dell'apprendimento e questo è vero dal
punto di vista qualitativo ciascuno di
noi può imparare un compito motorio
elementare come allacciarsi le scarpe o
una sequenza di movimenti complessi
pensate un ballerino che apprende una
coreografia delle più difficili
ciascuno di noi non di meno può
apprendere dei concetti molto banali ed
è però in grado di condurre delle
associazioni assolutamente eleganti e
complessi l'apprendimento in realtà e
differenziabile anche in termini della
nostra nei termini della nostra capacità
di ritenzione nel tempo dell'oggetto
appreso ci sono cose e con questo tutti
abbiamo familiarità che ri dimentichiamo
appena dopo averle imparate ed altre
invece delle quali riteniamo
l'apprendimento molto a lungo nel tempo
alle volte per tutta la nostra vita
cosa succede in una materia plastica
come il cervello per differenziare
queste forme di apprendimento
permettetemi di utilizzare qualche
esempio io credo che la grandissima
parte di noi si sia misurata magari
durante l'infanzia con il tentativo di
imparare a suonare uno strumento di
praticare uno sport dopo un certo numero
di lezioni tutti noi ci siamo sentiti in
grado di fare 20 palleggi senza far
cadere la palla a terra o di suonare la
marsigliese
a questo punto però alcuni di noi hanno
ritenuto di voler praticare uno sport
diverso hanno trovato la loro vocazione
artistica era un altro strumento
musicale
erano dunque è interrotto il
comportamento di praticare quello sport
o di prendere lezioni di pianoforte
quelli di noi che hanno cambiato strada
oggi non sarebbero in grado di fare tre
pareggi consecutivi e avrebbero
difficoltà a suonare una scala perché
questo avviene perché nelle prime fasi
dell'apprendimento quelle alle quali si
sono arrestati coloro i quali hanno
cambiato gusti in materia di sport e
musica
nelle prime fasi di apprendimento
l'adattamento che il nostro sistema
nervoso mette in pratica è un
adattamento eminentemente funzionale i
ponti in altri termini non si
significano i neuroni comunicano tra di
loro tramite neurotrasmettitori e
neuromodulatori nelle prime fasi
dell'apprendimento quello che accade e
che lungo i ponti definiti dalle sinapsi
il traffico aumenti più veicoli
transitano nell'unità di tempo su quel
pezzo di strada un aumento del traffico
corrisponde evidentemente ad un aumento
quantitativo del numero di informazioni
che vengono trasferite da un gruppo di
cellule ad un altro e dunque ad una
facilitazione complessiva della
trasmissione del messaggio
questa facilitazione e quella che ci
permette dopo dieci lezioni di
pianoforte di suonare la marsigliese o
dopo cinque lezioni di scuola calcio di
fare un certo numero di palleggi quando
tuttavia noi smettiamo di prendere
lezioni di pianoforte progressivamente
questo traffico va normalizzandosi la
normalizzazione del traffico e quindi la
riduzione rispetto alla folla mento che
c'era stata prima del trasferimento di
informazioni si traduce nella
progressiva estinzione dell'abilità che
noi avevamo acquisito si è costituito
una memoria di breve termine che ha
scarsa capacità di resistere agli
insulti agli insulti del tempo qualcosa
di diverso accade invece a coloro i
quali hanno continuato a prendere
lezioni di pianoforte e hanno continuato
a giocare a calcio
mantenendosi il traffico molto sostenuto
per molto tempo la mole di informazioni
in movimento ha imposto un adeguamento
strutturale i ponti che già esistevano
sono stati rafforzati
immaginate un ponte al quale vengano
aggiunte nuove carreggiate per
permettere lo smaltimento del traffico e
nuovi ponti sono stati costruiti questo
adattamento strutturale è un adattamento
evidentemente più resistente al tempo e
l'apprendimento con il quale corre la
definisce una memoria di lungo termine
e questa la ragione per la quale chi più
a lungo ha praticato uno sport è più
abile degli altri nel continuare a
praticarlo
badate gli ho detto che nessun
cambiamento che avviene nel sistema
nervoso per plasticità e irreversibile
così come dopo le prime fasi
dell'apprendimento lestingi
del comportamento finalizzato a
praticare lo sport oa suonare lo
strumento ha prodotto una progressiva
riduzione del traffico così una più
prolungata astensione dalle elezioni o
dal pianoforte potrà produrre un
rimaneggiamento in termini negativi del
nuovo apparato infrastrutturale del
quale il sistema nervoso si era dotato i
punti vengono demoliti ed alcune corsie
vengono ridotte questo ci dice che la
neuroplasticità può agire in entrambe le
direzioni può facilitare e rendere meno
facile la comunicazione tra gruppi di
cellule che in termini funzionali
macroscopici corrisponde a dire che il
nostro cervello si modifica tanto in
ragione di quello che noi facciamo
quanto le ragioni di quello che noi non
faceva provate a questo punto ad
immaginare gli stessi concetti correlati
alle funzioni più nobili più eleganti
per le quali il nostro cervello c'è
stato disposto pensate cioè a immaginare
quanti neuroni e in una porzione quanto
estesa del nostro sistema nervoso
quante sinapsi debbano collaborare e
cooperare armonicamente per procedere al
pensiero astratto alla colorazione
emotiva dell'esperienza all'esame della
realtà
tutte queste funzioni in ragione della
neuro plasticità sono funzioni che noi
possiamo apprendere nel corso del tempo
e possiamo andare sviluppando
innestandole su una dotazione genetica
che in relazione con i fattori
ambientali con i quali ci misuriamo
definisce il limite superiore delle
nostre potenzialità
in fondo innestando su questo elemento
il nostro possesso dalla nascita che si
chiama temperamento una serie di
comportamenti appresi una serie di
elementi ritenuti a breve oa lungo
termine
in altri termini innestando sul
temperamento il modo di pensare che noi
andiamo progressivamente imparando il
tono emotivo che noi usualmente
attribuiamo di una certa categoria di
esperienze
la neuroplasticità disegna per ciascuno
di noi diversamente dagli altri la
nostra personalità
le funzioni complesse ed eleganti alle
quali ho accennato sono funzioni che
vengono spesso alterate
nel corso delle malattie delle quali si
occupa lo psichiatra lo psichiatra si
occupa infatti di intervenire su quelle
che su quelle condizioni patologiche che
perturbano la capacità del paziente di
essere in congo la relazione con il
mondo circostante
interviene su quelle patologie che
perturbano il tono dell'umore che
perturbano la capacità di assemblare con
congruamente le percezioni che
perturbano la capacità del paziente di
pensare oggetti fuori dal campo del
sensibile e dunque di procedere al
pensiero astratto coerente con l'esame
di realtà per queste patologie
al netto delle norme numero di cellule e
del grande numero di aree cerebrali
contestualmente reclutate nell'esercizio
non si può che parlare dell'alterazione
di altrettanto numerose aree altrettanto
numerose cellule
la nuova frontiera delle neuroscienze
cliniche nel terzo millennio e questa
superare la definizione riduzionistica
che voleva attribuire ad un certo
settore del nostro sistema nervoso
esclusivamente una certa funzione oggi
si parla di patologie di network di
patologie di sistema e questo in ragione
della scoperta della neuro plasticità in
ragione peraltro della scoperta della
neuro plasticità val bene sottolineare
che se è vero che le nostre esperienze
ed i nostri comportamenti modificano il
nostro cervello
e se è vero che un cervello meno
funzionante è un cervello malato
vero è che nei pazienti affetti da
patologie di network non v'è farmaco più
potente di una revisione dell'esperienza
e di un rimodellamento del comportamento
c'è una precisazione da fare rispetto al
senso comune e diffusa l'opinione che
l'apprendimento corrisponda sempre ad un
guadagno di capacità adattativa
noi come tutti gli animali dobbiamo
rispettare una fitness evoluzionistica
siamo al mondo per auto conservarsi e
propagare la specie l'apprendimento è
certamente un ottimo strumento in questa
direzione
esiste tuttavia la possibilità che in
ragione della differenza che esiste tra
l'oggetto appreso e le strutture che
procedono all'apprendimento
esiste la possibilità vi dicevo che noi
apprendiamo dei concetti mal adattativi
pensate alla cattiva figura che fa lo
scolaro che impara che parigi è la
capitale dell'olanda e non della francia
quello scolaro al quale è impossibile
estirpare questo falso concetto prenderà
tanti brutti voti nel corso dell'anno
scolastico e geografia
noi possiamo procedere ad apprendimenti
mal adattativi che restano apprendimenti
restano frutto della capacità plastica
del nostro sistema nervoso centrale
ma perturbano il nostro funzionamento
nell'esperienza della realtà è il mio
caso io sono un tossicodipendente
come molti di voi io abuso di nicotina
ricorrentemente da diversi anni
questo mi accade in ragione della
plasticità del mio sistema nervoso la
nicotina e la caffeina sono le sostanze
d'abuso in assoluto più diffuse nel
mondo e questo non solo per ragioni di
legalità ma anche per ragioni di costi e
reperibilità bene io come il bambino che
si appresta alla scuola calcio ho fatto
la prima esperienza di assunzione della
nicotina o poi messo in campo un
comportamento di nuova e nuove e nuove
reiterata assunzione della sostanza o
modificato il mio cervello in modo tale
che il mio cervello oggi sia facilitato
nell'assunzione della sostanza
questo si traduce in un apprendimento
mal adattativo perché come tutti voi
sapete la nicotina insieme con gli altri
le altre specie chimiche contenute nel
nel fumo di tabacco rischia di uccidere
l'apprendimento mal adattativo è la
chiave per interpretare alcune delle
patologie più pericolose e più in
crescita nella popolazione generale in
questo momento alla stregua delle
dipendenze da sostanze sono molto gravi
le dipendenze comportamentali la
dipendenza dal sesso e la dipendenza dal
gioco d'azzardo impattano negativamente
la produttività e la funzione di un
numero sempre crescente di individui nel
mondo ancora una volta la strategia di
cura migliore più ancora che
farmacologica e psicoterapica è la
strategia che prevede un rimodellamento
del comportamento e dell'esperienza le
quali il paziente esposto gli ho detto
che le nostre esperienze e il nostro
comportamento cambiano il nostro sistema
nervoso
gli ho detto che il vostro sistema
nervoso presumibilmente sarà diverso
dopo aver partecipato a questa
conferenza
io posso salutarvi soltanto rendendo gli
edotti del fatto che siete
responsabilmente liberi di uscire di qui
e costruirvi il cervello che desiderate
avere grazie
[Applauso]